in this video we'll talk about allergy
allergies our body's immune response to
apparently harmless substance such as
pollen animal dander or certain food
many of the cases allergy doesn't range
in big symptoms generally it leads to
rashes or itchiness in the skin but
sometimes it could be life-threatening
allergy can be treated with
antihistamines and many other kind of
drugs in this video we'll talk about
these things in details so what causes
really allergy people are allergic to
many things such as let's say food items
like peanut gluten eggs crabs or seafood
sometimes apart from food items people
are also allergic to dust
wool or at let's say insect sting
so allergy could be caused due to many
reasons anything that cause allergy is
known as allergen
now these allergens are external
entities which leads to allergic
responses in your body
but also there are genetic
predisposition that can make you more
vulnerable towards allergy
and it happens in a syndrome known as
Hyper ige syndrome if you want to learn
about it in details the video is in the
I button
so allergens are substances that can
cause allergy
now many of the cases let's say allergen
is pollen grain and you inhale the
pollen grain via your nostrils so the
cellular and molecular players which
lead to these allergic responses are
mast cells basophils and ige antibodies
secreted by plasma cells
so allergies are also known as type 1
hypersensitivity and the onset of these
reactions are pretty much immediate in
order of minutes
so let's talk about the Immunology of
allergy in bit more details we would
take the example of inhaling pollen
grain and let's see what really happens
so in the airway epithelial cells we
would find there are mucous layers the
epithelial cells and underneath that we
might find uh antigen presenting cells
such as dendritic cells or macrophages
which can engulf these uh pollens or
allergens and ultimately display some of
them onto Class 2 MHC molecules
eventually they would migrate towards
the lymph node and show these peptides
to specific T helper cells and it would
lead to a t helper Cell Activation once
T helper cell is activated it
proliferates massively eventually it
differentiates into th2 subtype of T
helper cell th2 subtype cells interact
with naive B cell and instruct them to
differentiate into a plasma cell which
secretes ige antibodies ige antibodies
are key molecular players in the
allergic responses so what really
happens so let's say we are exposed to
any kind of allergen for the first time
in this case mast cells would be bound
to ige antibodies and mass cells has FC
receptor that can bind to these ige
antibodies question is where does these
ige antibodies come from this ige
antibodies are produced in response to
the allergy allergen exposure
now this phase is known as basically
sensitized phase mast cells are now
ready to degranulate but they didn't
degranulate yet next time when allergen
binds in a second exposure there is
severe degranulation of the mast cells
and this degranulation leads to many
cellular changes so overall it's
important to understand there are two
phases of allergy first is sensitization
phase
where the muscle is ready to degranulate
and the second phase is actually
degranulation phase where Mast Cell
secretes all the granules containing
histamine and many other proteins
so the molecular underpinning of this is
bit more complicated when IG binds to uh
FC receptor and allergen binds to it it
leads to activation of a signaling
Cascade which involves lean kinase
eventually it activates protein kinase C
or the map kinase Pathway to produce
several molecular components such as
prostaglandins cytokines chemokines
histamines Etc
now this Mast Cell degranulation leads
to bronchoconstriction it can activate
glandular secretion smooth muscle
constriction and vasodilation
mast cell granule composition is diverse
it has different type of granules such
as serine protease containing granules
which has striptase chymas histamine or
serotonin-containing granules granules
that contain proteoglycans like Heparin
which is a potent anticoagulant there
would be also lysosomal enzyme
containing granules cytokines are plenty
they secrete tnf Alpha interleukin stem
cell factors chemokines eosinophil
chemotactic factors all these things
and also a category of proteins that are
secreted are known as lipid mediators so
these lipid mediators are potent uh
activator of inflammation
so mast cells actually affect bacteria
and parasite infections so they are good
in our body but sometimes they are hyper
responsive to allergens and they can
interact with dendritic cells B cells
and T cells in an abnormal fashion to
give rise to problem in our body now
mast cells and basophils both of them
are secreting histamine and that lead to
all the changes
in during the allergy histamine which is
secreted by these cell types can bind to
several histamine receptors several
category of histamine receptors such as
H1 receptors H2 H3 or H4 receptor
present in different different organs
and all that has different kind of
outcomes
cellular outcomes one of the prominent
outcome is to evoke inflammation
now one severe format of allergy is
basically anaphylactic shock when there
is a severe Outburst of allergic
responses and that leads to dramatic
decrease in blood pressure suddenly the
Airways become narrow it would be harder
to breathe it lead to weak pulses rapid
heart rate nausea like feeling severe
blister like skin rashes and this is
pretty life-threatening if not treated
so immediately in those cases
epinephrine injection and followed by
that a visit to emergency room is really
important
so let's talk about the treatment of
allergy
so first of all
prevention is better than cure so
obviously one can avoid allergen if they
know what they are allergic to for
example sometimes avoiding seafood or
wearing Woolen clothes could save you
sometimes you are exposed to allergens
such as pollen grains which you have no
control on so in that cases
antihistamines can be very useful for
treatment
and they would be treating all the
symptoms of allergy
anyway epinephrine injections are
generally prescribed when the situations
are severe like in anaphylactic shock in
case of severe conditions steroids might
be applied such as cortisol which acts
like an immunosuppressant but before
taking any medication one should always
consult a doctor
that's pretty much summarize the video
on allergy you can get more notes and
flashcards in my Facebook page or you
can also follow us on Instagram for
notes you can find all the links in the
description you can support our Channel
via super thanks you can pay via paytm
PayPal or UPI your small contribution
would mean a lot for me
see you in next video